[Music]
what is the devil gene
the devil gene that's a loaded question
that's a very loaded question it's an
all-purpose revenge tool not all-purpose
reverse
revenge okay let's talk about the
origins of the devil gene so passed down
from where is it from from kazumi um
kazumi's family from the hachijo family
from the hachijo family to kazumi
heiachi married kazumi we know he loved
her but do you think he loved her or he
wanted the devil gene i'm gonna tell you
right now there's no way that hayachi
shed tears and he only wanted the devil
gene
there is no way like and you see my man
hey he'll do nothing but talk smack call
people kids just trying to kill people
he was legit crying there's no way he
didn't care about kazumi enough right
but he had to offer he had that was the
whole point bro the arcade intro of
tekken 7 faded retribution there's a
monologue where kazumi's saying my
dearest she's addressing to him that
she has to be the one to end her lineage
and she was talking about through her
precious son kazuya who obviously
inherited the devil gene i felt that was
so powerful
that that moment where she felt the
responsibility like she doesn't want to
unleash this devil gene or this evil
onto the world but heihachi wanted it
for himself yeah
and i thought that was powerful i feel
like he was torn between choosing power
and glory and love of his family well
but what the devil gene does is it gives
you unmatched power and a lot of
instances but that's the tragic thing
for heihachi is he couldn't use it he
couldn't use it no that's true he never
used it for himself
well i mean but
just to get back to it though what is
the devil jing right it it gives you
unmatched power you get the power to
turn into a devil in some instances you
get wings you get flight you get lasers
and on top of that it's so unmatched
that not only hayachi and kazia want it
or control it but other corporations
throughout the tech and world are
looking forward so that's how you know
is really strong but it's a gene that's
passed down from through the family
that's only inherited by what two people
at this point now three if you count
kazumi right it's only two people that
actually have kazumi as far as inherited
from somebody right she inherited from
somebody but i feel like it's if she
inherited it from somebody it's probably
just the lineage thing right it's two
halves of the family it could be another
sibling out there with the devil gene of
course but as far as we know we have
these two three if you count kazumi left
who have this power who everybody else
wanted and it's one of the most
strongest things in the tekken world
[Music]
so
[Music]
you